hello and welcome everyone to another
episode of multiple players I'm maxima
McGee sub enough for Chris waters today
and we are standing by for towerfall
almost that titanfall almost messed up
my intro but it didn't
we're about to jump into that but first
I'm gonna introduce some people and
they're gonna wave at you and then we're
gonna play on the far end here we got
Erte on the laptop he's gonna be
monitoring the chats with you guys have
any questions or just want to make fun
of Eric you can send all those messages
straight to him next to him we have max
Hobart and finally next to me Carrollton
hello and then that's my don't got 9
don't got none max Hobart at Twitter you
know don't got none so let's go ahead
and just dive straight on we just find
just playing a warm-up Dan I have to
make sure I'm leaning this way all right
okay let's just start let's just start a
standard yes to bring people up to speed
then we'll get into the variants the
different game modes all the different
things you can do this is towerfall
specifically tariffs all essentially yes
towerfall originally on the the oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah it was and now it's a
coming of course to the to the
PlayStation 4 on March 11th so nailed it
well real soon
and as I nailed it I got nailed by an
arrow that's it okay so let's pause on
the screen just okay so I'm player one a
green player and then it goes to three
and right right for viewer convenience
we are in order here we've organized
ourselves yeah oh no bubbles
we all got beaten up yeah except for
what did I get
yeah worst accounting I don't know I
guess oh I got the Koala
three - maximally cool so in addition to
shooting other players with arrows you
can also jump onto their heads a la
Mario and you know most other so many so
many times throughout the years and deal
damage that way just like and we have I
always forget about it but we have an
evade move oh and if you do that as an
arrow would be hitting you you you can't
touch it the arrow right you catch it
and it goes into your inventory you
don't give insta-death by arrows oh it's
incredibly exciting and you can totally
rub it in the other person's face shoot
you have all the arrows but blue player
is flush with Aaron I see the blue why
Erte hides like a coward and the game
does not appreciate do we mention why
Chris isn't here
I was gonna go with moving embarrassing
foot fungus that was gonna be my story
if you folks one of wish Chris well
while he's getting his embarrassing foot
fungus movie sure tweet at CT waters and
tell him about his embarrassing foot he
doesn't really have him very soon for
I'm sorry Chris come on I'm not even on
the board I got to get on the board man
touchdown all right apparently new me
okay
I'm aligned in the center one max per
team max max on max be some maximum max
violence in the king's court oh so now
we're gonna color so i'm i'm blue Archer
okay I'm I'm also blue our tournament
ready the archer with clothes I'm blue
dude you're blue ladies take care of ya
don't worry max I got this bouncing
around I got this oh but there's another
bramble arrow oh all the brambles of the
word oh it's on in the bran Blair I'm so
scared
get out ah oh my goodness I just evaded
that explosion all right all right green
again this time I'm gonna go around this
side you go that's it caught it oh no
whoa you folks at home cannot see me
manages whoa Jesus
I ducked that one Oh max have to be my
brilliant ah foil guy sorry
yeah it's a little blank Carolyn million
for the boat oh wait except we did not
go well Oh God alright I got I got him
oh I'll hide up here we go that's point
side up
no doubt oh you got Ike I got him I'm
dead yeah all right we kill each other
collect some arrows oh I would like a
rematch oh we gotta run it back a salty
runback we're gonna run back I'm very
okay I like how when one team has the
lead we get the crowns
yeah wait where's go get them
wow that's all you that was a bronze
yeah not our best not our finest hour
there me ngratulations to the evil side
of the couch Oh evil triumphs this day
the force of good were defeated what to
do did he do what are the variant gods
are gonna give us all right we're
getting that and let's let's not maybe
not do to ten let's go to five yeah just
in case that's fair just in case there
are more shenanigans Raj commanding over
not doing nothing I'm getting some sweet
bighead what's with oh we all have bomb
arrows oh my god this is like it's like
halo with rocket launchers I see you
what is that if you crouch you're
largely invisible for science oh god oh
god they're bouncing we don't have any
arrows there we go I bought you on your
big head oh my god come on somebody see
this is the tower fall right this is the
tower fall like that you fall through
the towers
next level arrow dodged dead body to
drinking his tears and then I just got
blowed up
oh sure you got them linked we all got
them wings what's that like red orb
awesome awesome
oh that triggers the lava things it was
committed to waste more babe I caught it
oh I thought they should have called
this really powerful it's so nebulous I
should have just gone with quality
exchange people in the Chad that I
always win one game totally why did you
wait what I like okay like that Oh cuz
it was okay so right now we're playing
with variants on and we're playing with
a variant called curse - okay so what
does it do so I don't know we both that
Eric and I both - into each other and I
think and then we exploded find out so
be careful about your dashes I will just
keep doing what I always do which is
never - oh yeah they explode I might -
for science yeah oh wow okay no I - my
dad man snatching equals death arrows
jeez no kill myself why not sure let's
go let's do it oh oh dear
oh oh oh and come on too busy caring to
Allah zero she's like oh I've got some
arrows right now feeling real good
Carol was like no the first dashing
you're totally out
Carolyn uttered well eric up there
playing the fool yeah why are you coming
to help oh my god Wow okay it's gonna be
broken by the end of this well get aa
teaser on it
oh my goodness don't catch that that's
how you catch an arrow don't worry I'm
coming back noise reload Ernest oh man
oh nice catch
okay there are only two arrows I know
that my entire arena and you have both
of them I'm not happy about it dark
stormy castle know what even hit the
moon oh yes there's the zombunny there's
the tower fall
there's your tariffs all the moonstone
gotta go is that a new stage we have
unlocked stone go ahead knock yourself
out hater of fun we go through there oh
no I gotta get out of here
oh my god around the world alright folks
thank you guys for tuning in and
watching multiple players know gamespot
livestream be sure to come back here in
a couple hours two o'clock Pacific for
game spots the lobby um I'm not gonna be
on it I'm gonna go do some work I'm Axl
McGee thank you all for joining me on
the couch and I'll see you guys next
time
you